die attila hildmann wenn sein kameramann
niederschlage das tut mir total leid
aber
[Musik]
heute treffe ich lars klingbeil 42 jahre
magister der politikwissenschaft seit
2009 im bundestag und seit ende 2017
generalsekretär der spd und er war
sänger und gitarrist der band sleeping
silent gute nachricht vorweg ich bin
nicht mehr der spd das heißt wir können
uns endlich wieder sitzen ausgetreten
und das schmerzt so würde sie ja gleich
ein blöder einstieg sie können mich
natürlich heute überzeugen im verlauf
des spiels direkt wieder einer kommt und
so kann ich heute gewinnen also gewinnt
alter von 2 das ist wie eine spd mal
verliehen jetzt wird der spielleiter zu
uns stoßen oder der spieler tritt in dem
fall ja ihr werdet eine zeitreise machen
ins jahr 2007 also relativ weit in die
zukunft und eure aufgabe ist es die welt
werden
[Musik]
so erklingen bei wir haben also mehrere
avatare sie können sich jetzt einen
aussuchen beruf welches tier und großer
hip hop fan absolute beginner füchse war
spontaner impuls in der es meistens
richtig also fuchs ist der fuchs durch
auch ein bisschen hinterlistig ja sind
sie auch ein bisschen hinter ich will
spielen jetzt ja dann nehmen sie diesen
würfel und jetzt geht man davon aus man
steckt denn da irgendwo ein und sind sie
als box das ist heftig sie ist haben
auch glaube ich ein bisschen
klaustrophobie so ein bisschen oder
spätestens gleich würde ich das
wahrscheinlich
wir sehen verschiedene spiegel und
laserstrahlen wir müssen ja heute die
welt retten der klingbeil
was wird schwieriger die welt drücken
oder die spd was glauben sie
die welt ok ich lass dir mal machen war
nicht gerade gar nicht
na das sieht gut aus dass sie gut das
was sie da machen
oh ja ein stück zurück dann ja
da klingen weil was macht die spd
eigentlich immer mit ihren vorsitzenden
dass die dann wutentbrannt gehen und
nach ihrer karriere eigentlich genau das
gegenteil von einem sozialdemokraten
machen sigmar gabriel dann macht die
deutsche bank das bild was läuft und für
den kann ich nicht reden den habe ich
noch nicht erlebt jetzt generalsekretär
ich habe andrea nahles erlebt die hat
ich finde ich super verhalten sich habe
martin schultze erlebt er ist
bundestagsabgeordneter martin
vernünftigen job was mit sigma ist weiß
ich nicht aber die andere haben sie
alles vernünftig verhalten also gibt
leider viele ehemalige vorsitzende fall
einer sich so verhält kann man ja nicht
sagen alle werden sie sich auch
irgendwann abwenden von der spd sauer
madrid ja nicht aus dass nur parteien
wissen sie das heißt sie wollen kein
vorsitzender werden
doch vielleicht irgendwann mal was ich
glaube gerade ein super job aber ich
werde mich nicht von meiner partei
ablenken aber ich merke auch sie sind
sie sind ein besseres shape also jetzt
mal sie haben abgenommen
sportlicher dass durch das städtchen
sich also besser aus als in echt gut das
soll das waren ein kompliment so ich
habe jetzt schon den zweiten ring es
fertig gemacht ich bin hier schon jetzt
nur noch rot grün ist im verein fehlt
nur rot das ist ja ist es zufall haben
sie extra erst grün gemacht dass das
absicht das ist im zeichen sie in der
sendung setzt sich jetzt ein politisches
statement dann müssen wir aber blau
lassen bei den weg
die afd die brauchen wir nicht ich
fürchte doch jetzt müssen wir den blauen
strahl auf den spiegel lenken und jetzt
zur decke das war's dann würde ich sagen
in den aufzug kann man nicht durchgehen
ja 1 oder 3 börse hin drei immer noch
dazu immer noch ganz oben
[Musik]
ok also wir sehen eine kehrmaschine
wir sehen verschiedene rohren wo sind
meine vermutung ist wir müssen diese
rolle an dieser apparatur anbringen ich
meine da es als mitglied einer
arbeiterpartei werden sie eigentlich
handwerkliches geschick haben oder
eigentlich nicht aber ich tue es nur so
ne da brauchen auf jeden fall aber wie
wir das mit dem handwerk zugeschickt das
macht meine frau die hat er wirklich
talent ja können sie gar nichts
handwerkliches ich kann nix ne nichts
kann ich meine lampe anbringen
sie sind ja so so der mann fürs digitale
kann man sagen sie sind die dorothee bär
der spd schöne story mag ich das kann
sie gerne so sagen ja sie ist in ordnung
die mögen sehen wo finde ich super aber
auch im digitalen bereich ist sie gut
oder zuhören um nicht alles was die
macht nicht richtig aber gegen die
vorratsdatenspeicherung ist hier auch
und so ich finde sie hat er schon gut
was verändert sich gerade ist das hier
eher so ein rohrkrepierer schottenrock
was qualifiziert sie eigentlich im
bereich digitales reich ist da in der
spd wenn man patron schuhe hat uns
selbst geführten twitter-account
vielleicht war ich werde 2009 im
bundestag bekommt und ich wusste wie man
ein iphone neu startet ich hatte eine
facebook seite und ich war jung soo das
hat mich qualifiziert und dann haben die
älteren nicht gefragt ob ich das machen
will und dass ich die ganzen schon dass
man wusste da hin und guckt sind ich hab
natürlich politisch mit dem thema auch
hier zu tun hat aber es war ganz
interessant weil es kamen viele kollegen
die wussten dass ich digital politik
macht und immer wenn die probleme im
iphone hatten oder wenn die kein
ladegerät dabei sind sie an meiner
generation ihre und ich kann ihnen
helfen
ich hatte mein ladegerät dabei holten
restart beim iphone kreieren sie helfen
ja ich bin ich kurz davor also also ich
würde folgendes vorschlagen das ist zu
niedrig was müssen wir tun damit
deutschland nicht den anschluss verpasst
an die digitalisierung
ich glaube erst mal er ist gut werden
das nicht eher scheuer macht ja da ist
das schon mal ein problem ich meine
generell wissen wir ja eigentlich was zu
tun ist wir müssen endlich beim
breitbandausbau vorankommen wir müssen
gucken dass wir die schulen
modernisieren
die einzige rohrleitung die noch
langsamer gebaut wurde in deutschland
ist die glasfaser hat das stimmt jetzt
sind hier solche da drin
wir schlagen damit team sind team
wenn jetzt söder und laschet werden
würde man schlagen damit aber ist schon
so oder so liest man das bei der spd
dann auch so was wenn die kleinen jungs
sicher streiten wer am stärksten ist das
kann man noch mal genießen wenn bei
denen mal der streit ist oder werden wer
glauben sie wird gewinnen von den beiden
jahren das waren markus oder so da wer
wird gewinnen heißt lachte das am ende
friedrich merz sonderrolle spielen wird
bei denen aber ist für lass uns mal
überraschen
ok ich schlage jetzt noch freundes vor
der hass muss
[Musik]
euro nicht runter kommen hier sitze ich
wünsche frau aber auch wie kann man
damit schmeißt also man muss diese bälle
dahin ja ich glaube auch diese diese
farbigen was war das denn weil ich das
jetzt noch nicht das futter gefahr dass
kein kameramann oder so hat sie die
kamera niedergeschlagen lassen können
sie dann in der antifa erhielt
kameramann niederschlagen das tut mir
total leid aber das war man ja aber ist
das noch aus der zeit der am theater ist
von daten ja auch gewohnt also ich weiss
nicht genau das war ja nicht in der
gewaltbereiten hat sich aber wir haben
die nazi zentrum uns demonstriert zu
hause also nur mit farbbeuteln gebraucht
nach nicht mal so was das ist ja ein
antifa dessen leuten die
antifaschistische engagieren so das war
richtig sie helfen mir schon wieder
fragen stehe ich habe noch nachhaltig
vergessen spiel sind da einfach ein
bisschen kalt ich versteh ich nicht
sie waren ja im präsidium förderkreis
deutsches heer und haben aber vorher
gemacht wie passt das zusammen also
kriegt ja aber wenn andere hin müssen
es gibt ja nicht mehr
verteidigungsausschuss jetzt nur
stellvertretendes mitglied und da ist
man immer bericht der stadt dafür in
bestimmten bereit
ich finde ja auch schlimm wenn im
bildungsausschuss nur lehrer werden oder
im landwirtschaftsausschuss nur
landwirte aber hat man sie denn da beim
deutschen jahr als ziel überhaupt ernst
genommen
es hat lange gedauert so finden sich
jetzt nicht problematisch als politiker
dass wir mal im präsidium eines
lobbyverbandes worden ich habe da ich
war dreimal auf sitzungen ich habe da
kein geld gekriegt ich hab doch also ich
hätte auch kein geld für angenommen ich
habe da politisch beraten was los ist
sondern ich sage ihnen wenn sie einmal
das jetzt komisch dass in so einer
situation nicht zu sagen aber wenn sie
einmal bei sich im wahlkreis ihrer
kirche sitzen weil soldaten aus ihrem
wahlkreis in afghanistan umgekommen sind
dann will man sich dafür engagieren dass
es ein ordentlicher ausrüstung und
ausstattung gibt man kann immer noch die
mir so ein einsatz der bundeswehr seien
aber wenn das politisch entschieden ist
wenn der bundestag gesagt hat wir
schicken der soldaten hin dann finde ich
muss man sich jetzt politiker dafür
einsetzen dass die nur gute ausrüstung
bekommen und das habe ich getan und das
finde ich völlig vertretbar und legitim
da ist es jetzt nochmal ich höre die
zeit läuft ab wir müssen jetzt noch mal
gas geben wir müssen wir jetzt noch mal
ein bisschen hier
sehr gut sehr gut sehr gut jetzt noch
großen wird
er hat es geschafft die menschheit ist
gerettet dankeschön zu sagen wir können
die brillen hochziehen
ich weiß nicht wer jetzt angst habe vor
diesem moment finden warum nicht
und ich versuche sie ganz durch nach
nach
dann heißt es jetzt sich wieder der
realität stellen oder wie man bei der
spd hart war
vielen dank es leben wahrscheinlich
[Musik]
wir haben nicht viel zeit du musst den
kanal der heute-show abonnieren
und neben mir auch weitere videos
klicken um die welt zu retten
ich halte den rücken frei